when i was young i always wanted my
superpower to be flight
but now i definitely have a new favorite
the boys episode 6 is here and this has
got to be one of my favorites so far
because
what can go wrong at a psych ward filled
with soups
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into the episode
the introduction of lamplighter and i
have a crazy theory involving stormfront
how she might actually be homelander's
mother and i got another surprise you'll
have to stick around till the end to
find out about so sit on down
grab a fresca and delicious brave maeve
bar
and don't forget to like and subscribe
because here
we go we begin eight years in the past
where frenchie sherry and jay
are doing drugs and discussing the
importance of golden girls the main
theme of which plays at the end of the
episode one reason frenchie loves the
show so much is that they made their own
feminine
just like the boys will make their own
family starlight gets her locator chip
taken out i'm curious how long starlight
can keep up this ruse of working with
the boys she now has this chip out and
ashley has asked multiple times where
the hell she is over the course of the
episode
where the [ __ ] is starlight no you dare
tell me you haven't found starlight yet
and the love affair between stormfront
and homelander continues as they share a
romantic kiss well
homelander bashes a criminal's head in
can we also just take a moment to admire
the message he got her with the flowers
thanks for a great day he's trying guys
okay starlight teams up with the boys
and isn't exactly greeted by
butcher warmly the last time they were
together he shot her way back in season
1 episode 7
and we know he has a hate on for soups
we'll see how he changes throughout the
episode eventually forming a bond with
starlight over their
mutual love for huey she informs the
boys about the emails she saw on
stormfront's computer last episode
unlike the screen we saw then where the
sender's name was blurred out we now
know this was stan edgar the head of
vaude stormfront and stan have been up
to something at the sage grove
psychiatric hospital and the boys are
going to find out what's up
we see this awesome ad for brave maybars
another satirical take on how companies
market social justice
not because it's the right thing to do
but because it increases their profits
last episode she enlisted the help of
the deep agreeing to help him get in the
seven if she helped him but now we
figure out what she really needed his
help for
retrieving the black box from the downed
airliner she and homelander didn't save
last season he wasn't able to get the
black box but got something
far more damning actual gopro footage a
passenger took of the event a train is
still struggling with the fact he's been
ousted from the seven the deep will use
this to his advantage to recruit him to
the church of the collective
after all anyone knows what's like to
get bounced it's me and he offers him a
delicious fresca the same thing the deep
was offered before he was recruited the
boys scope out the facility with
frenchie mother's milk and kimiko
set to infiltrate but before we head in
we get another frenchie flashback where
he's blackmailed into joining the boys
by grace mallory either he joins or his
friends
sherry and jay go to jail frenchie has a
history of finding creative ways to deal
with soups something grace wants to use
him for we'll later see him implement
these skills as he constructs a bomb
using the materials found in the ward
supply room stormfront tells homelander
that she can't hang out with him because
she has a meeting with her social team
something homelander finds out is a lie
when he visits vaught tower and she's
not there we'll find out stormfront is
actually checking in on the test
subjects at
sage grove but more on that in a bit as
starlight helps the boys gain access to
the facility
butcher's scope is on her he really
hates supes and no wonder considering
all the pain they've caused him his
entire life
starlight calls him out on this you're
just a bigot and a bully
i know another guy just like that he's
got a flag for a cape
this is probably the worst thing you
could tell butcher since there's no one
on the planet he hates more than
homelander the boys gain access to the
security room where they see a wide
array of captive
soups like teleport guy really small guy
guy who punches wall and guy with
enormous dick his name in the credits is
love sausage frenchie goes absolutely
ballistic when he finds out lamplighter
is working here
lamplighter was a former member of the
seven who burned grace mallory's
grandchildren the public doesn't know
this however there's a short scene where
stormfront sees the progress one of the
soups is making however when
he gets out of line and wants to see his
sister he's incinerated by lamplighter
this is our first time really seeing
lamplighter's power and it seems he
can't conjure fire out of thin air
rather manipulates it hence why he
always carries around his lighter while
passing lamplighter in the hall i was
totally getting an umbrella academy vibe
frenchie can't contain himself in the
two fight lamplighter accidentally
blowing the door to cindy's cell
or as i like to call her grown-up 11.
along with being impenetrable to bullets
cindy can crush objects with her mind
she crushes the head of a guard
just like rainer was killed a few
episodes ago and opens all the cell
doors letting the other soups run wild
in my episode 5 video we learned that
lamplighter was talking about a super
who
felt bad about something she did this
was cindy who was tasked with exploding
raynor's head under stormfront's orders
we don't get to know much about her
character this episode but the fact the
show ends with her hitchhiking this
likely won't be the last time we see her
a random suit blasts butcher starlight
and huey huey's injured by a piece of
shrapnel which starlight can't cauterize
because her power requires a nearby
energy source
and in retaliation for lying to him
homelander burns down stormfront's
trailer she senses something wrong with
him but it won't be until the end of the
episode until she reveals
why exactly she lied the deep has
brought a train to alastair adana the
head of the church of the collective
and a train isn't really about this i've
seen that documentary about you guys
it's not my type of [ __ ] a reference to
the church being like scientology but
alistar blackmails a train telling him
it's in his best interest if he were to
hear him out
he knows about a train's heart condition
abuse of compound v
and seven figure debt if a train joins
the church they'll have
two members in the seven so obviously
alastair dana has some hidden plans that
aren't exactly known yet
holed up in the storage room we learned
more about lamplighter and frenchie's
past
five years ago lamplighter was
blackmailed by the boys for some
incriminating photos we aren't exactly
sure what they
are just that grace mallory says he
looks good in whatever he's wearing in
return for their silence lamplighter
will tell them
everything he sees and hears in vaught
tower starlight ends up killing a man
when their attempt to take over a car
goes wrong she finds a baby seat in the
back and tells butcher
maybe once i would have cried over him
but
now he was just another person in our
way she's earning butcher's respect but
she makes sure to remark
we're nothing alike nothing lamplighter
frenchie and kimiko
are all characters who feel they need to
be punished with the guilt they hold on
to
we find out lamplighter attempted to
kill grace mallory in her sleep
but instead burned her grandchildren who
were unknowingly to him
in that bed frenchie was supposed to be
tailing him but that night ran to the
aid of his friend jay who was odin
only to leave jay and sherry in their
time of need and in the process
showing up too late to save the burning
children this may explain why sherry was
so easily willing to offer kimiko jobs
to the albanians when she knew full well
frenchie would hate that also fun to
notice is what appears to be a movie
premiere for a lamplighter film called
light and shadow
journey into night kimiko too feels
responsible for the death of her brother
and in this way both kimiko and frenchie
are two souls struggling with guilt
frenchie could have told the boys the
truth about what happened that night
years ago
to explain how he let those children die
but he didn't he didn't because he feels
he needs to be punished
what makes you think i want to be lit
off the hogo lamplighter tells them that
vot is using this facility to test
compound v's stability
it has a high success rate in infants
hence why soups like starlight the deep
kimiko and kenji were given it at a
young age but its effects on adults vary
wildly in order to stabilize it they'll
need
test subjects beyond that lamplighter
doesn't know vaught or stormfront's
motivation behind
it simply that he is there to literally
burn the evidence
huey's brought to the hospital and just
enjoy this may be a hero donate blood
poster the docs say huey will need a few
days to recover and it's here starlight
and butcher bond over their mutual love
for huey
never gives up on you does he and he
follows you around like a right little
pup
these two are definitely making some
progress elena finds the footage of
maven homelander and the plane crash and
i don't think
anything maeve can say will salvage this
relationship
even though maeve was using this footage
to save them from homelander
she's still complicit in the murder of
those civilians something elena will
likely never forgive her for
frenchie tells kimiko he'll leave her
alone he's realized no one can absolve
him of his sins and has realized where
kimiko is coming from with her brother i
honestly thought they might even kiss
here or that kimiko might try to say
something but i think the next step for
these two
is kimiko opening up and teaching
frenchie her secret sign language
grace arrives finally able to take
revenge on the man who murdered her
grandchildren but frenchie begs her to
spare his life
it won't help you
all you've been doing is ending his
torment the question then is
what's to become of lamplighter will he
help the boys as
penance for his past misdeeds love the
attention to detail here as we see the
scaffolding in stormfront's apartment to
repair it from all the crazy sex she and
homelander had to regain homelanders
trust she tells the truth about who she
really is
in her chest we see her liberty costume
and she shows him a bunch of photos one
of frederick vaught with goebbels and
himmler two nazi war criminals
stormfront goes on to say
bot was the most powerful man in that
room stormfront was born in
1919 in berlin later marrying vaught and
having a daughter
chloe who grew old and died of
alzheimer's she was frederick's first
successful v-injection
hear me out here but we have a few
pieces of info that point to stormfront
being jewish we know frederick vaught
performed his compound v experiments in
dakao a concentration camp during world
war
ii the actress who plays stormfront is
jewish maybe the show is just subverting
expectations by casting someone who is
jewish as a neo-nazi
but i can't help but think that
frederick was the one who changed her
not just
physically with superpowers but also via
brainwashing the other crazy theory i
have and i thought this was where the
episode might have ended
is that stormfront could possibly be
homelander's mother
in episode 4 we learned that liberty
disappeared in 1979 which lines up with
the estimated year
homelander was born we also know that
homelander grew up in a lab without a
mother
and that quote vots genius made him this
would also line up with homelanders
sexual need for a mother-like figure
and would be such a crazy reveal that it
would put luke skywalker and princess
leia's kiss to shame it's so crazy that
i wouldn't put it past
this show to do it but leave me your
thoughts and theories in the comments
stormfront tells homelander her plan to
create an army of supes to fight what
she calls a culture war
we are in a war for the culture
the other races are grinding us down and
taking what is rightfully ours but we
can fight back
she tells homelander that he will be the
one who leads them to this new destiny
and they kiss passionately it seems like
he's on board but what i'm still
scratching my noggin on is why stan
edgar the head of vaut and a black man
would agree to such a scheme
he obviously knows about the test
subject since he was sending stormfront
emails
what's going on has he been brainwashed
too by some sort of compound v
does he have an ulterior motive he
hasn't divulged to stormfront yet
and how does stormfront going missing
for 40 years play into all this
i'm hoping we'll get more answers next
episode but until next time
make sure to like and subscribe and
comment below what you thought of the
app for more bad takes you can also
follow me on twitter and instagram
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy's home
you